located in Romania around 400 feet below  the town surface is the Selena tirta an  underground theme park inside one of the  oldest salt mines in the world  [Music]  Selena torta is believed to be nearly  2000 years old during its time as a salt  mine it is estimated that over 3 billion  tonnes of salt was excavated from the  walls before mining stopped in 1932 this  underground hub has had various uses in  the past from a cheese storage center to  a world war two bomb shelter but it's  current usage is perhaps its most unique  in the early 1990s Selena torta was  carefully converted into a subterranean  theme park and museum this active park  includes a 180 seat amphitheater an  underground lake with paddle and row  boats mini golf course ping pong tables  and of course a ferris wheel over 2  million people have visited since its  opening the dizzying effect of the place  will leave you feeling like you've left  reality in this subterranean Wonderland  you  [Music]